[Music]
ironing your clothes seriously who does
this anymore you're going to throw a
jacket over that shirt anyway this is
about a cap successor not an iron man
the criminal organization known as laf
is targeting captain vassan
one of our military liaisons lau i share
the confusion sam
another acronym for an organization in
the mcu does this one stand for lazy as
f
because that's what all this acronyming
is starting to feel like and sam
this has to be subtle character says
something has to be subtle because it
will be oh so hilarious at how not
subtle it will actually
be cliche not looking before you leap
there's like a whole saying in
everything
sending intel to your hud right now i
love how tech in the mcu just works
every time to send extremely complex
data and audio despite loud environments
or long distances
and when i say love what i actually mean
is i am severely doubtful of
it did everyone brush up on all the
previous captain american films and
bring your notes because we're barely
four minutes in and we're already having
to remember who the
bat rock is and why we should care okay
fun fact this is why everyone working at
shield headquarters has to wear
lead-lined clothing
falcon is an equal opportunist when it
comes to taking a peek
instructions from inside an nba rules
committee meeting about james harden
somehow makes it into the script
red wing engage considering the high
noise interference environments it's
used in
i'm calling it a design flaw that
engaging red wing is done with voice
activation
it should be via glove or arm button
unless of course it's just an excuse to
say
red wing so the fan clan can excrete
some pleasure fluid
also i love how red wing just knows that
engage means go use your genital laser
to cut an exact hole out of this plane
at a very specific door seam
with no further instruction nice of bat
rock to be standing right by the doorway
so falcon could get the easy attack
on him and if bat rock was standing
right there when the door flew open
shouldn't even been sucked out of the
plane with it pilot gets hit by a
ricochet bullet and immediately dies and
slumps onto the controls to make the
plane dive to increase the tension of
the action scene cliche
we're playing all the hits today kids
geez how fast this guy secure this
hostage and get into a full jumpsuit
after he knocked falcon out by
checking notes kicking him so he hit his
back on something it's impressive for
sure
after the pandemic i swear it'll take me
20 minutes to get into a pair of jeans
let alone don a full body flights it
with a strap-on hostage
laughing about a basic front flip when
human life is on the line okay
fine this action scene is pretty amazing
it's clear that marvel is refusing to
pull punches with this stuff and putting
resources into making it look
spectacular
i guess i'll tip my sin cap with a quick
removal well done
still the guys in these helicopters not
being able to hit sam even once is utter
[ __ ]
and i will be sinning that red wing get
him off
but you didn't say engage engage is like
the pleas of the robot world
you have to say the magic word look i
don't have time to go all mythbusters on
this move and figure out the complexity
of matching the three-dimensional
movement of two independent bodies one
of which has
giant blades creating enough downforce
to stay in flight so let me just say
nope keep going we're close well
okay i mean i was planning on landing
the helicopter right here but if you say
so i will go ahead and
what was it again oh right keep going
also the commander told sam earlier on
the plane they were already in
restricted airspace so why does batroc
think traveling into a different
restricted airspace will make a
difference
this face ah heads up you're about to
fly into libyan airspace not sure why
this matters because once again the
commander told sam that they were
already in restricted airspace they're
already committing all the illegals
how many choppers do these random
terrorists have we've seen at least two
blown up and this third is followed by a
fourth loaded to the gills with
missiles for a last-second tension
builder i'm just trying to figure out
the plan here
hijack a plane take a hostage and then
was the plan always to jump from that
plane
even though they had control of it they
had all the equipment to do so but if
falcon never shows up they just fly
direct right but still they have a flock
of fully loaded choppers at the ready
just in case i mean there's planning
ahead and then there's omniscience and
this feels more like the second
also now is as good a time as any to
remind you that hawk fly abandoned an
unmanned plane to just continue on its
way flying over the desert
sure they showed us it went to autopilot
but that sucker was flying to libya too
and it's never mentioned again and i
need to know how did they stop that
plane
this works working on next level
high-tech equipment outdoors in a sandy
environment
online there's just been a lot of a lot
of stuff about steve actually
crazy crazy conspiracy theories some
people they think that
he's in the secret base on the moon mcu
and on
showing us recognizable washington dc
architecture but still feeling the need
to splash washington dc across the
screen
sam even said in the last scene he was
headed there i appreciate they're giving
this shield the white glove treatment
but papadoc was clearly putting his
fingerprints all over that thing
i say you're gonna make me ask why
didn't you take up the mantle
damn it's almost not fair that marvel
can just bring in don cheadle off the
bench for a few minutes and add this
much gravitas to the proceedings in fact
it's
so not fair that instead of taking
another sin off i'm adding one for how
not fair it is
so deal with it half hour before last
call
i can't guys i have to prep for
tomorrow's session we've seen a lot of
stories on the dangers of alcohol but
here we have a situation where going to
get a drink would have saved a guy's
life
i actually can't say how i feel about
that messaging but i do appreciate the
tip to flip the storytelling norm
any second now bucknutz is going to
burst through this painting but why does
he wait
if he's going after this group bust the
hole grab your guy and get the buck out
of there
also considering the winter soldier is
borderline unstoppable does he really
even need to perform this kind of
subterfuge
his target is now more aware of the
attack than he would have been if bucky
had been hiding in the guy's room or
dropped down from the ceiling
and the target has a better chance to
get away because bucky has created the
obstacle of drywall that didn't need to
be there
sleeping on a hardwood floor i said
hardwood
you're a civilian now maybe the show
will explain how this is possible maybe
it won't but i can't imagine there is
any explanation for how a murderer on
the level of bucky barnes would be
allowed to freely walk amongst the
population
regardless of the fact that he was
manchurian candidated he still
killed a ton of people i like bucky i
like seeing sebastian stand in the mcu
but i will never be able to buy he can
just go get some baby back ribs at his
local chili's whenever he wants to this
could have been handled differently
this should have been handled
differently with your history the
government needs to know
that you're not gonna
gonna what root route for the home team
what was rule number two nobody gets
hurt it's a big one then why isn't it
rule number one james buchanan barnes
would be excellent at tv sins
look i know that you have been through a
lot
but in case you confused it with de la
croix that you drink even though it
tastes like you're licking the bottom of
a swampy rhinoceros foot
uncle sam these kids solely exist so
that someone gets to call him uncle sam
and everyone can turn to their neighbor
while watching you go get it
uncle sam like the military but shut up
cece we all get it
try the whole online dating thing it's
pretty crazy
also there's that whole you're a former
hitman for hydra thing perhaps remove
the part of your profile that reads
former hitman for hydra but now i say
hell no to that
hmu speaking of that why does no one
recognize bucky i know when he was
winter soldiering he had the half mask
but there have been pictures of him in
newspapers without the mask i'm not
saying he's tom cruise trying to walk
down the street in peace but sam out of
falcon gear in torres had some random
guy walk up to them and call them
avengers if there are strangers that
know
torres there's surely plenty of people
who would recognize bucky
tiger photos i mean half the time i
don't even know what i'm looking at it's
it's a lot sound like my dad your dad
laments that dating apps are full of
tiger photos
keep a couple games around for boring
chefs and i picked up battleship and i
swear it has nothing to do with your
previous connection to war or any
thematic ideas of subterfuge the show
we're on is playing with
it was a random game i promise
uh hit why aren't you using the
electronic noises when you're clearly
playing electronic battleship
also why have you only placed two of
your ships and why do you have three
hits on this ship when she's only marked
one
and why are you surprised she guessed b8
it's the obvious next guess
after she hit on e d and c8 and later
bucky's gonna take two guesses in a row
sho obviously doesn't know how to
battleship correctly
there's no word for someone whose kids
die
it is fairly recent but the sanskrit
word villama has come into usage
it means against the natural order of
things and though i could add a sin for
the show not mentioning this
i'd rather this be a sin for the type of
grief that i can't even imagine and
no one should have to experience a date
this is a great reveal
even if you see it coming it perfectly
conveys the depth of what bucky is
dealing with and how his past actions
have affected so many other lives marvel
does the pew pewing as well as anyone
but they can also bring the character
moments
and the tears i'm not crying you're
crying susie
disobedience so i don't know how
jurisdiction works here but i don't have
to place you under arrest taurus saw
what this guy
just did to the cop does he really think
pulling a gun on him was going to be
effective
doris survives this i knew it falcon
really
dainty butterfly hands is what got this
guy to falcon you know what i've always
wondered
how do you guys make a living oh oh i
know let me try this one
it's a tv show and it's fiction so quit
asking dumb questions because you're
ruining television shows and i like the
other narrator better anyway
how am i doing i understand their
priorities are to secure a loan at the
bank but
maybe leave a smidge earlier and give
the food to those in need before the sun
bakes it in the back of your truck
oh my god sam you better look at this
hey you better come take a look at this
cliche and news position at the same
time
you're straight up mocking me now aren't
you marvel look when you're using cgi to
de-age kurt russell 40 years younger and
stuff him into a captain america suit
technology has officially gotten out of
hand
yay more previously on segments do
previously on segments make sense and
serve a purpose yes yes they do
will we keep sending them yes yes we
will no one will be seated during the
14 seconds of unzippering sequence also
the unzip reveals a great void of
nothing
and i never realized how let down a
zipper could make me feel defacing
school property
not my captain america i remember
sneaking into this locker room before
each game intentionally entering a men's
locker room when you don't even have to
this is the job john all of it is it's
always been in the job description
job description what would that even be
captain america must have delicious
juicy perfect buns and be able to pose
for photos while also able to kill
unimaginable terrorists from space with
a shiny circular winter sled
star spangled man with a plan and all
that roll commercials
isn't this soup it comes with
expectations bro
exactly it's no good stuffing a sock
down there
trust me also john has been doing the
captain america thing for two weeks now
so he's
definitely heard all about the
expectations of the suit so why is lamar
in the scene
[ __ ] lamar you can't just punch you
at problems anymore
the climaxes of almost every movie in
this franchise would beg to differ
[Music]
[Applause]
appreciate the new music i really do but
it's still masturbatory logoing and you
know how we feel about that around here
using a high school marching band to
introduce [ __ ] captain america
i'm sure they're very talented but was
lady gaga not available or
little big town or like kid rock i bet
kid rock was available
i don't think they're holding county
fairs currently
disrespecting your sensitive bits and
really the inguinal area in general
ah son sarah haynes disney could you
please stop masturbating for
five damn minutes was it really
necessary for walker to bring his
gun to this event yeah that and flags
tend to start majestically waving in the
wind
yeah i think that's just the wind but
what i do have
is guts uh something captain america
always had always needs to have and i'm
gonna need every ounce of it
if by guts you mean your stomach and
intestinal tract that only comes in
about a hundred ounces think i'll take
the flashy gadgets and super strength
please
good to see you too buck tv show called
the falcon
and the winter soldier goes a collective
58 minutes before it does
any falcon and winter soldiering what
could be bigger than this
this guy falcon is going to wave the
image of a bad guy needing a beatdown in
front of a trained assassin in murder
remission currently struggling with a
friend identity crisis
is anyone thinking clearly today what
victory
androids aliens and wizards every time
we fight we fight one of the three
i mean except when you don't mysterio
whiplash obadiah stain yellowjacket
the winter soldier i read the hobbit
in 1937 when it first came out bucky is
like the guy who makes sure to point out
he first saw dave matthews at a college
frat party no one cares and don't be
like
bucky kids i mean mainly because he's a
killer but the bragging thing is
also bad a sorcerer is a wizard without
a hat
that's sorcerest um also the dungeons
and dragons players handbook
clearly states on page 99 that a
sorcerer is defined as nerd
i'm coming with you no you're not how
did bucky even get in here sure he's
been pardoned but does that come with an
all-access pass to a military base of
his choice
in case you confused it with munich
north dakota these linear communications
devices manage to stay intact after
diving out of the plane but
mine fall in my cereal bowl when i
sneeze how is that even fair
what is the point of this needless
sleeve ripping does the leather somehow
block the power of vibranium how many
jackets does bucky even
go through why not just take the damn
thing off entirely
i have all of that on camera you know
that right but
why falcon leaps out of the plane to go
on with his mission unsure if bucky was
even gonna follow or not why would he
hang around
or send his robot familiar to candid
camera bucky's plummet wait is this
supposed to be comic relief
you're doing the staring thing again do
you mean the thing where he
looks at something with his eyes yeah
total dick move hey come on man i'm just
messing with you come back
while on a highly sensitive mission that
requires stealth and focus falcon
decides that
this is the best time to be jovial read
the empty warehouse room in the middle
of a forest overseas on a secret mission
falcon
sure is lucky that these bad guys who we
assume do not want to be caught
ignore this very obvious kerfuffle bucky
runs up to this truck breaks the door
off and you're telling me that the
driver of truck 2 does
nothing there's no way they didn't see
him now yes
they know that the person in truck one
isn't a hostage but surely this is still
a less than ideal turn of events
and something at least hornworthy mind
you the masks do look very cool however
carly has already given herself away as
one of the thieves so does she really
need to put it on now
at this point she's just obstructing her
own vision
i always wanted to do that oh crap am i
starting to like bucky
sam is wasting his abilities here why
land on the truck and start a fist fight
when you can fly
just pick these guys up one at a time
and fling them into the forest okay
first of all
close those doors before your goods fly
out of the truck second why are the
trucks still rolling down the road like
it's a normal caravan
sure we want to see a mobile fight on
the top of two trucks but would they
want this
no they'd stop traffic kick some ass and
zippity-doo-dah down the road
third carly heard redwing coming and was
all ready to rivet to shreds
here comes a [ __ ] helicopter and
she's suddenly surprised
no just no hello girl kick your ass
setting aside show has time for this sam
didn't fare much better against
that little girl so maybe he should just
sexist the [ __ ] up
unlucky bucky stucky under a truckee
just let go
of the truck that was a bad idea
i'm not sure the show wants us rooting
for carly right now but i am
totally rooting for carly right now
super nice of that car to be completely
absent when lamar should have been run
over but also appear to break his fall
and how in the hell after 80 years or
the eighth supersoul just running loose
i mean one getting produced every 10
years i would guess
seems like pretty simple math falcon
it's 20 miles of the airport you guys
need a ride
no they really don't falcon can fly and
bucky can speed run
why can't falcon just fly them there the
script needs them in that vehicle but
sam and bucky are doing just fine on
their own i see a guy hanging out of a
helicopter and tactical gear i need a
lot more than lamar hospital sam would
be the wizard android or alien of tv
since
they call you robin hood whoa whoa hold
your roll there
i'm not sure that you oh robin hood is
in the public domain is there anything
disney can't get their hands on
there is someone that
you should be glad to see the pronoun
game survive decades of soviet
brainwashing
i'm surprised they were able to find him
this easy that guy is mostly associated
with an alias
you think you can wake up one day and
decide who you want to be
wait are you saying i can't be an
astronaut but i just bought a new
goldfish bowl
none of these people are recording on
their cell phones yeah we did some field
ops back in the day
never heard field ops used as a
euphemism like that but okay
do whatever you gotta do with them then
send him off to me this [ __ ]
blase attitude to therapy is still a
thing
suppose that while you're sleeping a
miracle occurs
when you wake up what is something you
would like to see that would make your
life
better i'll give all the sins back if
falcon says does crippling back pain
count because i got the spot right here
they're really smarts
in my miracle um he would he would talk
less
exactly what i was going to say isn't
that ironic only if you're using the
more set dictionary
and if he was wrong about you then he
was wrong about me bucky's feelings here
are heart-wrenching i wish someone would
comfort him and help him understand his
value outside of false equivalencies if
only there were a therapist that
actually knew what the
she was even doing you know what doc i
don't have time for this
and yet you still spent the last five
minutes bantering in soul gazing
i'll see you outside careful that
tearaway sleeve will fall right off
i know that look what's wrong honestly
no disrespect to therapists everywhere
but she is really bad at her job
she brings in two men with super
abilities who need professional guidance
and has them just stare at each other
while tolerating their childish banter
here's an idea have that very clearly
distraught x assassin
sit his ass down and do some of the hard
work of therapy
but you guys have rules of engagement
and all kind of authorizations you have
to get
we're free agents we're more flexible
how is that now
earlier walker said that the falcons
take his government property and that he
himself was kind of the government
plus if falcon hasn't been jetting
around the globe on an avengers jet so
far he's been working with the us
military
i'm not so sure the falcon is a free
agent is what i'm saying
okay great now you've blocked the road
so you can just run back to the plane
and escape
what are you doing he blocked the road
and he's not far away he can still make
it back
what are you doing the plane's ready to
go and you can still make it
what are you doing you're just going to
run at them they've got
guns the five seconds it takes for them
to shoot you down won't make a
difference so you might as well run to
the plane
it's the most pointless sacrifice i've
ever seen on screen i just rewatched the
first transformers movie
we're gonna go see zemo gasp dramatic
reveal
intrigue callbacks end of episode
excitement
almost two full minutes of regurgitating
stuff we already know
not a baby bird marvel i can chew my own
plot food okay
the global repatriation council knows
that for many
it wasn't that easy wait it wasn't that
easy
last time i said the blip was a bad idea
someone reminded me that hulk said he
wanted everyone to return
safely certainly took into account their
psychological health as well right
i know i'm beating a dead pedantic horse
here go figure but all i'm trying to say
is that marvel has still not wrestled
with the moral ambiguity of returning
half the population
after being mourned as lost for five
years
i'm gonna send them for it every chance
i get reset
restore rebuild why go with rebuild when
restructure is right there and would
keep the res going
this is why everyone hates you marvel
can anyone explain to me why cap's
helmet is designed to push his ears out
like this
and it's not the actor because i had the
same thought even when there was a chris
wearing it
i'm just saying there are so many better
options in this captain alfred america
design
do you know who i am an ever-increasing
caricature of american entitlement
that's bordering on parity and starting
to hinder my ability to buy into the
story
am i close in case you confused it with
berlin take my breath away
that time wasn't exactly a picnic this
saying
picnics are not easy and generally suck
there's wind and critters
in bumpy seating and ant jerry's about
five hard lemonades into a rant on
border control you know honestly when
something is terrible it should be
called a picnic
what are you talking about you want to
break zemo out of jail better question
is why are you only talking about it now
what part of falcon's personality makes
you think he wouldn't have forced a
conversation about what happened in
there immediately
especially considering there's time for
an entire jailbreak sometime before we
get to this conversation
he is crazy but he still has a code yeah
and i've been on the wrong side of that
code bucking so have you
this show is desperately trying to use
this sam bucky conversation to give us a
valid reason bucky would go all
finding zemo and break him out of jail
but it's clearly only because the plot
needs it to happen
which honestly is happening a lot on
this show what's the book you're reading
machiavelli i've watched this prison
break scene several thousand times now
and i still can't figure out what's
supposed to have happened here
bucky asks him what he's reading as if
he's the one that put the key card in
the book but
how and when zemo's apparently already
been
reading the book so why hasn't he seen
it before and then they just happened to
walk bucky through gen pop during
chess time and completely miss him
tossing this note to one of the local
grand masters
speaking of the note when did he have
time to write it and with what
and how did he know there would be a
situation where just two guys are
sitting at a table wouldn't that
he will kill you tonight note have been
confusing if he had to drop it at a
table with several inmates
and why does mobby fisher here even
believe this random note from an
absolute random stranger
then the escape completely yadda yaddas
how zemo got
outside the building preferring just to
show him use his card on a couple
interior doors
as if he somehow knew exactly where he
was going i mean i suppose i could have
just thrown a
this works on this whole escape but then
i wouldn't have gotten to use the moppy
fischer joke and no one keeps me from my
name puns
no one so all this time you've been rich
apparently so it's a good thing too
because we need a jet for any of this to
work
who cares that his asset should have
been seized marvel's got a marvel i
guess
he's out of line but he's right tv sends
defenders
james you will have to become someone
you claim is gone
is it santa claus oh please tell me it's
santa claus playing soccer in enclosed
spaces
or really at all hell he does look like
me though convenient doppelgangers
conventional gangers
[Music]
this opening street cry montage fast and
furious is on for some time
also do you want broken ankles because
this is how you get broken ankles
i love these character has to eat or
drink something disgusting to prove they
aren't an outsider cliche
a power broker really my response from
the future when someone tells me this is
their favorite episode of the show
somehow makes it into the script sure
in the grimiest crimiest underbelly bar
in this hive of scum and villainy people
are still
whipping out their phones to record this
kerfuffle this would be one of the most
violent group of cameraverse people in
history anyone trying to snag some
social media clout down here
would basically be trading their lives
for likes onto basebook
or whatever site obvious criminal
stereotypes use for social media these
days
the breadcrumbs are gonna for free what
the bakery is gonna cost you baron
using carbohydrates for evil instead of
good aside from the overall stupidity of
leaving his phone on vibrate sam lets
this phone rumble for several seconds
before he's then asked to answer it on
speaker
why didn't just reject that call
immediately also i'm throwing in a sin
for sarah and anyone else who calls
someone without texting first
this is 2021 sarah show some respect for
mobile protocol
also also i'm not sure which i'm more
impressed with that you're managing to
get two full bars of service down in
this dungeon or that you took the time
to ask someone here for the wi-fi
password
kill them deus ex power broken uh x
sharina x bothana running these heels
calling these heels was is a big
difference
i mean maybe but if someone said i was a
serial killer or i
am a serial killer the difference starts
to shrink a bit doesn't it sharon we
need your help
stating the obvious what's going on
sharon what's going on is that sharon
has a rack of clothing that will
perfectly fit you that's
twice in one day that sam has had a
perfectly tailored outfit change without
having to resort to gym shorts in an
old ratty t-shirt that says orgasm donor
on the front
crowds and yes i would have seen this
before the pandemic 2. there's just more
people on my side now
also we spent so much time on this party
montage that i'm beginning to think this
episode is 30 establishing montages
16 actual plot and 54 trying to justify
all these people being willing to work
with
[ __ ] zemo having a secret entrance
that is unlocked and can be opened with
a simple push
you know who he is right this is baron
zemo
i know you've heard of him too right of
course because every single person in
this entire universe is familiar with
every single player in these movies i'm
just saying 90 of america couldn't even
tell you who eugene goodman is and that
dude is about as close as we get to a
superhero on this planet so excuse me if
i'm doubtful
every bounty hunter in the city is here
we gotta go seeing does not contain a
boba fett
also i get that every bounty hunter is
after you but how did any of them know
you were here right now
and why would they share that info with
anyone else not my pig not my farm
charlotte's web deniers this guy waits
until such the perfect moment to block
convenience's rocket launcher they might
as well have left the director in the
shot screaming action
it's an every action movie falcon
stressed would be excellent at tv sins
but also every time these two fight i
get lethal weapon vibes and honestly
their chemistry is so good i'm somehow
not hating it
no i've watched enough mythbusters to
know you can't just
know where to shoot a pipe so it
explodes like that no matter how skilled
you are
you think you can do these things but
you just can't zemo
also now all of a sudden zemo has gone
from an intellectual manipulator with an
avengers grudge to a wealthy vigilante
wearing a mask with dead eye aiming
skills and incredible fighting prowess
since when did zemo turn into the mcu's
version of batman
so they just happened to pick an empty
open shipping container that somehow
leads to a magical escape car
did you see a mr tumnus in there as well
were you offered some turkish delight on
your way through
guess i won't be needing this anymore if
we get the job done do you really think
they're gonna sweat us on the how
putting the ends before the means and
what i mean by that is that this show is
more concerned about having dramatic
episode ends without worrying about what
any of it actually means
thanks taurus saying a character's name
out loud because it's been so long since
they've actually been in the show that
we've forgotten they exist
i was wondering when you were going to
show up is like a path of camoya beads
really the best way to do this
anyone could have seen those and pick
them up before bucky did i guess marvel
just wanted to walk on the convenient
side of the street for this one huh
hey yo sorry guys it's it's basically a
disease at this point
it is time i mean i hope so i've had to
wait through two minutes of previously
on and logoing to get here
i actually might need to take a snack
break i think i have some turkish
delight around here somewhere
nope that's a rolo how could you free
him well you see there was this card in
a book that had a tiny note that made
two men fight to the death followed by a
guard murder and an outfit change none
of it would have been possible without
an impossibly deep understanding of the
layout of the prison mind you
were you followed no how can you be so
sure
because i know when i'm being followed
well that answers that then
no reason to double check anything do we
really have to litigate what may
or may not have happened there's nothing
in litigate you straight shot the man
one thing i'm really enjoying so far
about the mtu is that we're getting more
in-depth looks at characters that
weren't much more than side pieces in
the mcu anthony mackie is kind of
killing it in this show and i'm now
firmly in the sam fan camp
sammys falconers desire to become a
superhuman
cannot be separated from supremacist
ideals
anyone with that serum is inherently on
that path
that supremacist and the entire
neighborhood got together for a ceremony
it's like a week long maybe they're
doing the same thing for donya and by
sinful coincidence they are
one of the workers killed was the father
of two if they're all watching and
listening to this on their phones how is
there one single audio stream
shouldn't we be hearing this traumatic
news and surround sound wearing a car
seat belt
as a belt buckle keep an eye on him keep
an eye on him sam and bucky are
obviously very good at what they do but
letting zemo roam around loose seems
like an odd choice
zemo's clearly capable of causing a lot
of damage quickly he [ __ ] shot the
only lead they had
you know for a group of people who hate
the grc they seem to be surprisingly all
right with keeping up grc propaganda on
the walls
well what's your name maybe i can make a
call i'd love to see that call get made
i'm sorry you're who oh you mean the guy
that helped break baron zemo out of jail
yeah yeah yeah we're totally gonna help
you just stay right where you are
turkish delight was always my son's
favorite strangers with candy then she's
no different than him
or anybody else we fought so then you're
happy to help her too
right just like you're helping him you
know the guy brewing cherry blossom tea
and making an afternoon snack it just
feels like sam and bucky are playing bad
guy favorites and zemo's in the lead
because he can put them up in some posh
mosaic suite
you always used to tell me if you're
doing something and it makes you scared
it's probably because it's the right
thing this is terrible advice
i didn't think there could be another
captain america until i met you
worst pickup line ever or possibly best
but either way
back then there was just good and bad
but the world's more complicated now it
was never just good and bad
kids lack the ability to use foresight
and perceive the complexities of good
and bad which is why we have warning
labels on laundry detergent
but first we pay our respects to mama
dania but why i know she meant a lot to
you in the cause but carly's probably
the most wanted person in the world
right now
she really needs to get out of some of
her public appearances i can't figure
out why she's in this graveyard without
a cap or sunglasses or anything
she will move in fast take her by
surprise no i want to talk to her alone
i think john might have the better idea
here but i can't figure out why just the
two of them showed up
the grc wouldn't send some backup once
again carly and her group are the most
wanted people in the world
and they are all super soldiers might
need a little more firepower than
captain faux merica and lamar hoskins
can you show us the way
what the hell man i'm really starting to
like this john walker he's a little
snarky and rough around the edges but he
seems to have a good head on his
shoulders
i'm really looking forward to his
character growth as he wrestles with his
anger and
comes out on top of it all we may even
get that sweet camera shot from below
where he stands heroically with
shield in the foreground it's gonna be
epic
also if zemo was going to bring sam and
bucky along with him this whole time
then why tell the girl how a little
secret
or they're very bad not to be trusted
wouldn't that lead to the little girl
being immediately concerned and
suspicious when he shows up with
four guys you got 10 minutes and we're
doing things my way
setting an arbitrary time limit just so
someone can ignore the time limit and
ruin everything when it was all going so
well cliche
how did none of the other flag smashers
notice the mysterious figure looming on
the second floor even if their backs
were turned during the ceremony carly
glanced towards sam several times which
should tip them off
i know walker's trying to prove himself
as a worthy successor to captain america
and he's been pressing hard to get carly
captured but this transition from steve
rogers wannabe into a five o'clock
shadow [ __ ] feels like we've missed a
good five or six scenes with walker and
hoskins that would explain his dissent
i realize they've got to get us to the
ending of this episode but they've
skipped over what could have been some
really interesting scenes to get us
there
it doesn't matter that we see how zemo
got out of the handcuffs we just need to
see that he can
i lost her this place is amazed and yet
you found each other and zemo finds
carly without issue
neat so carly gets through walker
hoskins sam and bucky but gets derailed
by
zemo in a pistol yeah that adds up
also how does he keep getting guns
this episode is 17 michael myers head
tilting
stealing what did we miss
well i missed the part where the split
party found the dungeon map and managed
to reunite in a maze
did you find the violence they've been
destroyed how did carly not already know
this
she just saw zemo stepping on them i
didn't give him the shield
well steve definitely didn't four
episodes in and we're still having the
shouldn't have given him the shield talk
do you want four sins show because this
is how you get four cents
he's actually proven himself useful
today by shooting
carly okay sure he gave candy to kids
like a creep and found out where the
funeral was going to be
but i'm pretty sure they could have
attached a tracking device on someone
and figured it out without the turkish
delight
what i'm saying here is this show really
goes the extra mile to justify trusting
zemo and they really shouldn't
the dora milaje are a dick to tiles also
why would the dora milaje chuck the
spirit captain america when zemo was
right there for the kabobbing
was aio seriously going to murder
captain america because i think ao was
seriously going to murder captain
america
was she seriously going to murder battle
star because i think she was seriously
going to murder battle star
and why is zebo still here i can't
believe he pulled in your chapel
i can't believe no one has followed him
are the dora milanji afraid of sewers
everyone just casually looks at it
yep that's a holy wind down probably
leads somewhere else oh well
if i were to kill you it'd be
meaningless see i'm shaming
hello john walker note to self the next
time you ask sharon to keep an eye out
for walker moving in on carly's base
ask her to give a warning before he's
directly on the base
thanks sharon sho doesn't want to take
the time to show us the scene of john
taking the serum but is more than happy
to show us zemo making tea and 38
discussions about how sam should have
taken the shield
[Applause]
why would anyone from carly's army react
this way to jon's serum or not bucky's
been a super soldier this whole time and
they haven't acted scared of him
this useless clock alright this part is
hard to watch but i have to ask why
everyone stops fighting each other i
understand walker bucky and sam stopping
to check in with lamar but the flag
smashers wanted to kill walker and he's
very distracted at the moment why would
they stop going after their target
cool john's probably just going to ask
this guy for the quickest way for him to
find carly so he could calmly arrest her
for killing his friend
i i mean that hit to the face seemed a
little over the top but he's got him
subdued so he can once again
calmly obtain this infra holy [ __ ]
what is happening good luck getting
blood out of that shield john
i'm pretty sure you just can't run that
through a dishwasher so you're telling
me that there was a black super soldier
having to remember this guy's name when
all i can recall is his alias
what if they're going to repeat scenes
we can't repeat sins
why'd you give up that shield i'm gonna
be waking up in the middle of the night
screaming why'd you give up that shield
for the next year
after hearing it so many times on the
show why does this even need to be in
the previously on segment we know that
will be said at least once during the
actual episode super soldiers sure do
run a lot but
why having the super serum running
through your body means you don't have
to run or really perform any kind of
exercise you can just eat tater tots and
donuts all day while watching hot and
cleveland marathons on tv land why are
you [ __ ] running john
why if walker is struggling with a
flashback wouldn't he be seeing it
through his own eyes
i mean i don't really want to see
first-person perspective of this guy
getting his head smashed by cap and face
crunch but it would at least be accurate
also you show the flashback was in the
previously on one minute ago and we
could all
really use a break from being bashed
over the head by the scene
[Music]
this is like watching a bird fly into a
window over and over again
try something else that works why remove
protective gear in the middle of a
choking out of your opponent
the few seconds it would take to unclasp
the chin strap would have given sam the
advantage
so if america here rips off sam's wings
which in addition to creating an excuse
for a new suit
also somehow renders him unconscious
great oh
so bucky does know how to hit something
other than the massive bullseye right in
front of him
maybe hold on to that until captain
america has been retained by the
authorities or
sam at least has a chance to catch his
breath and stand up she's going
we'll never find her but only because
we're told so if they want to find
anyone else on the planet they just pack
a cell phone or enhance a satellite or
phone in wakanda she winds up in new
york by the end of the episode so
surely they'd be able to track oh i
don't know planes
captain america killing a foreign
national in public
it's kind of like a big deal like like
international
incident big i agree which is why i
don't understand how sam still has the
shield that is a [ __ ] murder weapon
that should be in evidence who even
allowed that to be cleaned also this
episode ruins my scent from last episode
about not being able to get the stain
out of the shield
and i'm petty so these chairs are off
limits but this microwave and oven are
okay guys
wait yo you forgot the wings cable
and somehow sam has the authority to
give away the tech to torres
for reasons also remember torres
consider yourself extremely fortunate mr
walker
and return the shield to us with
expedience how do they not know that sam
has the shield
torrez and many other officers were at
the earlier grc operation and saw sam
walk off with it
ah yes when i'm approached by a strange
woman clomping towards me my instinct is
to look at her shoes rather than her
face
you know because identifying someone's
footwear is incredibly useful
valentina allegra lafontaine awesome
this reveal means we might be one step
closer to a thunderbolts movie or tv
series but as i learned from wandavision
this is most likely just a teasing not
something we'll see resolved on this
series
marvel could have benefited from the
teachings of the great german scholars
the scorpions the mtu knows how to tease
me but i'm not sure they know how to
please me this show really wants us to
believe that carly is an intelligent
person who's able to evade the
government with no issues but then there
are scenes like this where she returns
to the scene
of a grc takeover and that is not what a
smart person that knows how to avoid her
enemy would do she might send some of
her people to do it but she'd never show
her face there again
also why did the grc decide not to watch
these locations in case carly and the
crew showed
up they just threw up some caution tape
and flyers and shrugged their shoulders
like well guess we can all go home for
the day because obviously carly's hiding
somewhere we'd never find her
[Music]
littering
what do you suppose the conversation
between bucky and the dora malay was
like hey i'm gonna trick zemo into
thinking i'm going to kill him with a
bullet to the face
so you all wait over there out of sight
until you see him
his pants and then walk dramatically
over so that he actually shuts his pants
when his fate sinks in
we will take him to the raft well glad
that all wrapped up so nice and tidy for
bucky
and i understand the grc has their hands
full with the captain america they
appointed being a power-hungry loony
bird but are sam and bucky really not
going to be in any kind of trouble for
breaking zemo out of prison i mean
that's a federal offense
hey paying ao watering plants at night
what i think it is a deflated mastodon
testicle yes
yes it is also let's go ahead and stir
up a lot of pain and bad memories for
this poor guy again
that was so much fun the first time
around they
will never better black man
be captain america and even if they did
no
self-respecting black man would ever
want to be there is so much truth in
this bit of dialogue and while the show
often struggles with presenting moral
complexities this is perfect
it almost makes me want to take all the
sins back for complaining about why
didn't you keep the shield talk
i said almost but i'll at least give one
back for this amazing moment
sarah i'm coming home and i'll just
immediately hang up on you after my
exclamation
nothing cryptic or weird about that way
to potentially freak your sister out for
no reason sam
in about 10 years we'll have this thing
fixed
it also feels like the sam goes back
home and fixes the boat sequence takes
10 years but you don't hear me
complaining you know
except for right now and the entirety of
this video
betta and elling's dad cannot get up
before noon
kids keep showing up hungry but are too
proud to ask for any help and you're
just like mom
feeding every kid in the neighborhood
and luckily sam was present for the
handing off lunch portion of the day so
he could realize the way he's going to
save the boat and his family which leads
to a revelation about what it means to
take up the shield and become the next
captain america
i mean what if he'd slept in how do we
get it off the truck
no but seriously if bucky hadn't
randomly been there how would they have
gotten it off the truck
i'm in fixing together the only way to
work out pointless grudges since 1817.
i'm lucky flirting with your friend's
sister if they don't add an l here at
some point i will send this show a
hundred times this is just a sin to
remind me to do that because if i don't
sin i forget
she's a very mean person
sam and bucky are kicked off of boat
fixing duty and walk away bantering back
and forth for a few seconds
great fine but at least let us hear what
they're saying rather than force us to
turn on closed captions to read their
conversation over the swelling music
sam is a dick to trees also if the
shield got stuck in the tree when it was
thrown how is it not destroying this
padding four falcons fingers
when steve told me what he was planning
i don't think either of us really
understood what it felt like for
a black man to be handed the shield i
heard an apology
i'm sorry so when you retired it it
made me feel like i had nothing left
well look at that
bucky's doing some deep inner healing
suppose we shouldn't be surprised now
that he's no longer seeing that terrible
therapist
and yes she deserves yet another sin
this is our history we can't lose this
fight
my goodness there's more reflecting in
this episode than a fun house full of
mirrors
this training montage does not contain a
survivor song so
sam's just hanging out training back
home with captain america shield and
no one is coming for it i swear to steve
this episode is shot after shot of
shield porn it's at least 68
shield born so with no money and barely
any resources how is carly managing the
technical infrastructure to lead a
rebellion
everyone in the park hears this why does
new york get a title card but earlier
washington didn't be consistent show we
could have sent you for making obvious
title cards twice
show ends on 15 seconds of sam staring
at something we can't see
which in addition to being a dick move
will also be a huge disappointment when
it's revealed next week it's actually
full of receipts and expense forms that
have to be organized for falcons taxes
there is a complete lockdown at the grc
meeting in lower manhattan
but not a lockdown on the rules of
wearing earrings on the job these things
look amazing but someone's going to rip
them out of your ears in a scuffle
also if you thought we weren't going to
sin news position just because it's
audio only we probably need to get to
know each other better so we can avoid
these kinds of miscommunications in the
future
saying there's no fly zone in effect
while using footage that specifically
appears to be shot from a flying vehicle
and yes i get it they can put cameras
wherever they want but my cognitive
dissonance kicked in and it made me
angry
[Music]
it seems like some serious effort would
have gone into applying this fake face
so why rip it off to prove it's you tell
them a secret only the two of you would
know like the diameter of his left
testicle
also this tech is incredible it doesn't
even rip off face hair or remove
blackheads
relax no one's looking for me here even
if they were you made it really easy to
spot you now that you've removed that
super high tech face mask for absolutely
no reason yes you won't be needing
wait crap rewind it
[Music]
guess you won't be needing this anymore
phew thank you
you're risking a lot of coming here i
hear pardons arnolds are cracked up to
be anyway
how are these two speaking to each other
right now
hey bobby you get that gas grenade done
yet nah
i'm still trying to design that opening
mechanism that separates into three
geometrical pleasing sections to let a
neon green light shine out between them
damn it bobby not everything has to be
an homage to the matrix we need those
things like yesterday
[ __ ] you frank i'm an artist so the
building was attacked while sam was back
home he then danced his new wings and
flies to new york where carly waits to
see him in the sky before initiating the
smoke bomb attack meaning
all these chuckles were just hanging out
in the conference room with doors they
could have run out at any point
yes mcu officially passes on a main
character title for the first time and
it's
absolutely badass and to those who would
say that mackie could never carry the
shield as well as his predecessor i have
one thing to say
that's cap i mean i guess we had to find
a new interpretation of the head piece
but functionally how does it stay stuck
to his head is the middle strap section
so tight that it clamps it in place how
do you properly contemplate saving
people when your brain is being squeezed
by a cranial jock strap he's wearing a
jock strap for his face and now you'll
never unsee it
you're welcome you cost me a lot of
money
oh good we get to go back to the bat
rock plot line everyone was clamoring
for swear the only time i want to hear
the word bat rock again is if christian
bale ben affleck and will arnett start
touring as a death metal band
camera sends a spiral staircase down the
middle and blasphemes vertigo in the
process cliche
captain america suddenly forgets that he
has a shield despite spending 56 percent
of the last episode training with one
that's how you feel you should sit this
one out well you know i ain't gonna do
that
bucky's already sitting this one out
considering that since his phone call
started he's just
standing there walk and talk bucks walk
and talk
seriously bucky you had one job since
everyone can talk through their magical
earpieces why would sharon take
this long to check in with bucky and how
does a phone call with carly distract
buggy in the first place and yes i
already seen that but
well that's one down how'd you manage
that murder
chopper's about to take off [ __ ] it i
don't fly man that's your thing
at this point these communicators are
just magic right mcu is just like
look we need our characters to be able
to throw quips at each other at all
times and we're not letting things like
distance or logic stop us
you don't think lamar's life mattered i
mean to be fair as much as we knew about
them they might as well have dressed
them in a red shirt and been done with
it so maybe direct your question at the
writers
on this one john
parking meters i'm digging a lot of this
action i really am but it sure does seem
like the formula for these mtu finales
is just going to be punch punch wink of
themes punch punch plot twist punch
punch false resolution punt the big
stuff to the movies doesn't it
yes put in your earbuds that you not
only happen to have on you after being
rushed out of the building but are also
charged and completely inconspicuous
also not punctuating your text messages
you're better than that captain america
or red wing or whoever the hell sent
this text however the hell they sent it
a little birdie told me
alright that's enough did they tap into
her earbuds did she answer a call this
show's text sells more convenience than
7-eleven cases murphy's and wawa
combined
we're gonna count down from five when we
get to one you're gonna grab the control
this countdown is complete tension
building nonsense
all you had to say is when i take out
the pilot immediately grab the controls
instead of relying on two people
reaching the count of five at the same
time in a situation where you don't even
know how long it's going to take you to
pull off the move
if she gets to five before you and tries
to grab the controls you might end up
taking both of them out and killing
everyone on the chopper hey
random plot device lady i'm taking out
the pilot when i do grab the controls
in the scene oh yay murderous crapped in
la
merica is fighting the murderous flag
smashers and i guess i'm supposed to be
rooting for
the scene to end
a vehicle gets treacherously suspended
above a fall with innocent lives at
stake
boy we're playing all the action cliche
hits today kiddos and
now maybe we're supposed to like this
guy again john walker is rocketed
through his character arc without
earning it so fast he's basically the
game of thrones season 8 of the mtu
he's just a normal dude pushing a
two-ton truck with a jet pack and
somehow his back doesn't break
he doesn't even have a pulled muscle
afterwards beautiful people bought into
that bush
the comment section every time i remove
a sin somehow makes it into the episode
it's like they want us to see this tech
that somehow tracks thermal footprints
left through boots and say it's wakanda
tech so
anything goes and we can't do that well
we could
but we don't want to are they whistling
to
find each other what a terrible idea do
they not think that whistles can be
mimicked have they not seen the hunger
games
so you're the power broker i felt a
great disturbance in this plot twist as
if millions of voices suddenly cried out
in apathy and were suddenly
disinterested where does it end
apparently just above the temples
and honestly your cowl is the most
distracting thing i've seen since the
ball brawl
sharon must be feeling pretty confused
right now you know with sam rushing to
carly rather than to her they're both
dying of gunshot wounds here
i'm a black man carrying the stars and
stripes
what don't i understand oh captain my
captain look this show has its share of
bull but this
this is the good stuff i know i've said
it before but one last time for being
willing to go there marvel
i doff my cap walker walks into a media
frenzy where
no one asks him why he's there what he's
doing why he's in captain america gear
or what it feels like to be useless
super nice of the raft to provide
plot-spilling satellite radios for the
prisoners
it's the same but black i mean now
you're just saying the quiet part out
loud
i uh i have to tell you something this
segment of bucky finally truly making
amends with his past is powerful and
would probably have earned another sin
off if it weren't for the fact that it
included a positive nod to this terrible
therapist who needs her license revoked
and in no way deserves credit for any of
this
[Music]
stalking wait so you made an entire
section of the museum dedicated to this
man with his full name
and information on display and you
didn't get permission first this is the
same man who didn't even want to be
bothered about any of this just a few
days ago so this is not only a huge
gamble but probably unethical this would
be like holding a particular award till
the end of your award show because you
think you know who's going to win and
you could use it for your own purposes
can you imagine i told you in the last
episode if this wasn't fixed i'd add 100
sins
and i'm nothing if not a super
consistent completely fair man of my
word
it would have made me judge jury and
executioner with zero accountability
is he wearing a parachute no
no he wasn't coming
i'm going in cover me perkins
i trust people trust no one mr mulder
so now that you've stopped fighting
what do you want
[Music]
peace we are the united states
government we don't do that sort of
thing
he ate sucka uh
and my favorite vitamin i might add be
yourself if you can't love yourself
how the hell you gonna love somebody
else good morning
john john [ __ ] toast good morning
good afternoon good evening and good
night
we're not playing no more we can't let
the same [ __ ] who are put back in
power after the blip win
you sound like you're from london
kids big ben parliament again sir
that stolen lima bit one of your
prostitutes right in the face
and she says she can't go to hospital
because she's quote
tripping balls you will be sorely missed
you little
bat-faced piece of [ __ ]
i have never well i'll get you in all of
my 23 years
pirate sanctuary do what you want cause
apparently three you
are a pirate snakes why did it have to
be
snakes can anybody tell you that this is
the private club of the satan's helpers
nobody hit me to that dude you have a
real problem now
so leave your weapons and follow my lead
[Music]
fire is good fire is good yes
fire fire is our friend end of intro to
funeral speech
good afternoon to everyone i'm kenny
powers
they started a war as soon as they
kicked us out of our new homes and onto
the street
people all around the world need me
millions of them i don't quite
see how you cherish the memory of the
dead by
killing another million and uh
personally i think you're a idiot i
thought we'd been
chosen you choo choo choose me
where is she where is she i don't know
he is gone he's gone from here the evil
is gone
we could have been a team i could have
been a contender i'm batman
this is what happened when your life is
at stake you do
anything by any means necessary
it is a mandate you don't want the truth
because deep down in places you don't
talk about at parties
you want me on that wall you need me on
that wall
yeah and when i see priests in the
street i never ever stare at him and yet
i'm careful not to look away see because
i want to make the freaks feel
comfortable
i'm about to have to consider the optics
the optics are whatever we show
we have to believe in what we're doing
to support us gentlemen you can't fight
in here this is the war room
sir are you supposed to be here
like to take his face off
red wing see if anyone in there has
flight training
sorry i'm having trouble understanding
right now
please try a little later
stay down let me do this all day
sharon blocking my light haha sharon
okay i get it